المتوقع ان يساعد الاتفاق في التمويل واسع
النطاق لاوكرانيا من الجهات المانحه
والشركاء الدوليين بحسب صندوق النقد
الدولي الذي اكد انه توصل الى اتفاق على
مستوى الخبراء مع اوكرانيا بشان حزمه
تمويل مدتها اربع سنوات وتبلغ قيمتها نحو
15.6 مليار دولار دعما لها فيما تواصل
معركتها ضد روسيا
من المتوقع حدوث انتعاش اقتصاديا تدريجي
خلال العام المقبل في ظل التعافي من
الاضرار الجسيمه التي لحقت بالبنيه
التحتيه الحيويه على الرغم من استمرار
الوضع الراهن ومنها خطر حدوث مزيد من
التصعيد في الصراع
ياتي الاتفاق الذي لا يزال يتعين ان يصادق
عليه مجلس اداره صندوق النقد الدولي بعد
مفاوضات على مدى شهور بين خبرائه والسلطات
الاوكرانيه ومن المتوقع ان يناقش المجلس
الموافقه على الاتفاق في الاسابيع المقبله
اتفاق لاقى استحسان الولايات المتحده
برنامج صندوق النقد الدولي طموح بالغ
الاهميه لدعم جهود الاصلاح في اوكرانيا
بما في ذلك تعزيز الحكم الرشيد ومعالجه
مخاطر الفساد وتوفير الدعم المالي الذي
تشتد الحاجه اليها
خبراء صندوق النقد الدولي يتوقعون حاليا
ان يتراوح التغيير في الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي الحقيقي لاوكرانيا لعام 2023 من
سالب ثلاثه بالمئه الى واحد بالمئه